[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID SHIVE: So I'm glad
to be here today talking
a little bit about where I work.
So in full transparency,
the conversation
is powered by Robitussin
and cough drops.
So I can't be held accountable
for anything I say.
I brought my notes up to help
me out a little bit with that.
So please work with
me, bear with me.
So I am the CIO.
My name's David Shive
and I am the CIO
of the largest
property management
organization in the world.
Think of, like,
Jones Lang LaSalle,
we're bigger than that.
I am also the CIO of the
largest fleet in the world.
So think of UPS' great big
fleet, or Coca-Cola, or Avis,
or places like that.
Our fleet is bigger
than all of that.
We are the purveyor of the
largest collections of arts
and antiquities in the world.
We're one of the biggest
design and construction
companies in North America.
So think [INAUDIBLE] Turner
or Clark Construction.
We do those bodies of work.
We do all of this
effectively with technology.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about partnership
and effective use of technology
at the end of this discussion.
But we do this on behalf of you.
Many of you in this space.
If you're a US citizen or a
visitor to the United States,
you're part of who
we do this for.
So who are we?
We're the United States General
Services Administration.
And we do all of this on behalf
of the citizens and visitors
of the United States, as
well as the federal agencies
that support operations
in the federal space.
So that's a pretty
picture of our place.
That's one of the many buildings
that we manage and control,
along with the Pentagon
and the White House,
and others like that.
So all of this disparate
business mission,
we're effectively the back
office of the United States.
We look after land, and
buildings, and physical needs.
Our workers are our
property managers,
they're purchasing agents,
they're policy writers.
We write policy for the
entire federal government.
They're technologists,
we provide technology
for the federal government.
And we do this on behalf
of our federal partners.
So that our federal partners can
focus on their primary mission
areas, which are
protecting our borders,
and accelerating the mission
to Mars, or curing cancer.
We do this kind of mundane
work, so that they can focus
on their primary mission areas.
Because we've been doing
that for a long time,
we've become a proving
ground, a test ground,
for new and enabling
technologies.
So that what we can
try before we buy,
and try before we use
in GSA, we can then
scale across the
rest of government.
So talking about that
digital transformation role.
Because we've used technology
as an enabler for a fair amount
of time, we've been able to take
what we've learned internally
and scale that through our
federal acquisition service,
we're the purchasing agents
of the federal government.
Or through internet of things
with our building automation
technologies, and we'll scale
that through government.
Taking our IoT learnings
and moved on from there.
Let's go to the next one.
So how do we do this?
In this role, we
do a few things.
One, we try new technologies.
We tracked world class
talent into our organization.
And we did this for
a couple of reasons.
We're steward of
taxpayer dollars.
We're spending your money.
A shareholder, when they make
an investment in a company,
they're going into that knowing
that they can potentially
lose that money.
You, citizens, you're not
making that investment
or obligated to do well for you.
That's a significant influence
on how we do our technology
and why we do our technology.
Because of that, because we're
dealing with taxpayer dollars,
we share everything.
We share our code, we
share our playbooks,
we share our configurations,
we share talent,
we share our infrastructure.
Because we're doing
this with your dollars.
In addition to being
able to share everything,
the ideation that
we do, the builds
of our minimally viable
products, how we deliver,
how we determine what works
and what doesn't work.
We get some really good
outcomes by doing that,
by rapidly iterating
to things that work,
and rapidly pivoting away
from things that don't.
And that allows us to
be sort of a training
center for effective
use of technology,
not only in the federal
government, but elsewhere.
Some examples are people
from my team, GSA IT,
are now the chief
technology officer
for Department of
Homeland Security,
or run the federal
practice at Salesforce,
practice at Box.
Because they learn
what they can do,
what the art of the possible
is in federal government
here and then export
that out elsewhere.
Some of the results of this
mindset, this innovation
mindset, are up on the screen.
We've been able to rationalize
our applications down
to about 20%.
The way we deliver,
we've been able to save
17.8% of our costs,
while also increasing
employee satisfaction with
what we do and how we do it.
That's over $100 million
recurring annually
that we've been able
to save while driving
higher, more effective
adoption of technologies.
And my customer
satisfaction rate is 91%.
Let that sink in for a
minute, 91% in the IT space.
I'm very proud of that.
So to the comms
team, this is where
I'm going to kind of go
off script a little bit.
So you're free to go get a
cup of coffee or something
like that.
[LAUGHTER]
So Tarik, at the beginning,
talked about partnership.
And that's where I want
to end this conversation,
because partnership
is key and parcel
to everything that we do.
When we started our
transformation play in 2011,
there were zero agencies in the
federal government that were
using cloud-based email, zero.
And so when we said,
we need to find a lever
to drive transformation
into the federal government,
we had to be very intentional
about what we did.
Because the technology piece,
frankly, is the easy part.
The hard part's organizational
change management,
driving adoption of new
technologies into a new space.
And so we had to be very
intentional about what
partner we chose.
We happened to choose Google.
So we partnered with Google
to flip from 17 mail systems
into a cloud-based Gmail system.
Saw some really
good outcomes there.
And what that did is
allowed me to do two things.
One, in my organization to
say, look, if you transform,
it's not the end of
your business world.
Your business world will be able
to continue to grow and thrive.
And that provided a
springboard to the next step.
And we said, OK, what's
the next logical target?
We had employees storing
data on their laptops,
and on their phones, and in any
space where they could possibly
find it.
We said, well, let's put a
controlled environment there
and move that out to the cloud.
So we moved to Google Drive and
had all 16,000 of our employees
move their data out
to Google Drive.
Really great outcomes.
People saw they could
still access their stuff.
They could get to
it from anywhere.
And then they saw
those great outcomes.
And then we moved
to Google Docs,
and then we moved to
Google's scripting
to allow us to do
business process.
And then we moved on to Google
Cloud, amongst other clouds.
And so that lever,
that's the thing
I want to leave everybody with--
when you're choosing
your partners,
you're transformation agents
in your organizations,
choose very carefully.
Because they can be the one
thin line, the discriminator,
between success and failure.
In that regard, we're super
proud that we used Google
as that primary transformation
agent from the very beginning.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]